the prophet Muhammad S.I wasallam told
us whoever builds a mosque for Allah
Allah will build for him a similar house
in jenah and we know the great reward
that will not only be gained but rather
will fill your grave after your death
whenever someone prays there whenever
someone gives Shah in the Masid whenever
someone learns something in the Masid
yes that will be something that you'll
have on your
scale
how are you guys doing I'm joined with
the main man with the plan Ali D Ali da
how you doing brother you're right to
see it's been challenging times hasn't
it let's be honest it has but we have a
voice me you zishan and the rest of us
the da Squad the da team the sect
alhamdulillah we've been able to really
get through to a lot of people and make
a change and we continue hoping to do
the same thing but there's an individual
as you know called Douglas Murray some
people call him gutless Murray because
of the amount of times he's been
challenged to debate and the amount of
times has refused that challenge doesn't
have the guts doesn't have the guts uh
this individual has come out and
fabricated lies fabricated lies not just
about Muslims and about and all that
stuff which he does and he's he's got a
lawsuit with me has to put his little
suit on and walk into the court and
defend himself because of actually he's
got we've got hearing with him not only
that but now he has to defend himself
again because he's lied about the
religion of Islam let's take a look at
the clip and come back sure of course
that Muhammad the founder of Islam
himself beheaded massacred many many
Jews famously there one one battle in
particular um and the the Banu it's a
story you can find in the um in the
Quran and the Hadith uh and of course
this is because the Jews would not
accept the revelation of Muhammad such
as such as it was and so they were one
of they were are seen within Islamic
tradition as being one of the first
people who turned down the opportunity
to join Islam and as a result of course
Muhammad uh uh decapitated hundreds and
hundreds of Jews um so that's not a good
start now there's a few things I just
want to point out um of the CF number
one it's not benu it's benu and that's a
major difference because quray is
actually this the tribe of the Prophet
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam so
he didn't even get the names right in
fact this is a a serious error and this
shows you the incompetence the
negligence the foolishness of this
particular individual number two no
serious historian okay whether they are
Muslim or
non-muslim spanning the works from is to
to the
book to all of these figures that have
written s all the way up to uh Karen
Armstrong and these all none of those
have a characterization of the events as
he has put it in fact what he said is
completely a lie the there wasn't such a
pact that he there wasn't such an series
of events where the Jews of B were said
come into Islam and if you don't they
will kill you this is a lie in fact the
Quran very clearly
says that there is no compulsion in
religion that truth has been made clear
from falsehood and that particular tribe
and there was many of those tribes that
we don't to speak
about for now there other tribes the
Jewish tribes that existed with the
prophet as you know that they had a PCT
with the prophet Muhammad there was a
kind of Constitution that protected
their rights and allowed them not just
to practice their religion as Jews but
to have a parallel legal system where
they can rule on their own religion that
was the freedom that they were afforded
and this was 5 years into the medinan
period where the Prophet mhammad had the
PO and in fact what really took place
was was that the combatant the males in
that tribe the combatants the male
combatants because women didn't as much
in the medieval period engag in fighting
they conspired with uh the Pagan Arabs
at the time they conspired with them in
a particular battle which actually
resembles what's happening in Gaza which
we'll talk about in a second called the
battle ofab or the Confederates which is
mentioned in chapter 33 of the Quran and
is mentioned the S as well and because
of this conspirac conspiracy to kill and
to kill the Muslim people
uh the the male combatants or the males
among the particular B tribe were
decapitated not by the prophet mhammad
but in fact by who they accepted as an
arbitrate Arbiter so this is actually he
gets so many things wrong here and in if
if we want to go into detail there was
actually figures like and others who
were males who were spared because they
were seen not to dishonor the uh some
serial writers they didn't dishonor the
treaty so the point being is that this
cannot be compared to what is happening
now can it Ali because in our religion
not only is
there which is the idea that there's no
compulsion religion in our religion
there is this idea that there's no
killing of the civilians no and the
prophet Muhammad Ali wasallam mentioned
very clearly that there's no uh there's
no killing of women there's no killing
of children and there was no killing of
women and there's no killing of children
and how could it be Ali and tell us
because this man you know him and you've
been following him as well a little bit
how could it be that they think that
they have the moral High Ground after
all that they support and all that
they've done how dare they come to the
people of Islam and the religion of
Islam which was it's the only religion
of the medieval and ancient and
Antiquity period of that kind of period
out of Judaism Christianity and Islam
that says there is no virtue of a white
man over a black man an Arab over a
non-arab it's the only you'll not find
the equivalent of these statements yeah
you will not find the equivalent in the
Old Testament or the New Testament yeah
so how could they think that they have
the moral High ground and they're
supporting people like the IDE of who
are indiscriminately killing women and
children babies heads are being blown
out tell us more about this I mean to be
honest in a nutsh it goes back to a deep
hatred and dehumanization of the Muslims
at large um wherever they are whoever
they are for that matter and you can
very see clearly that they do not
condemn IDF they do not condemn what's
going on in Israel why because they do
not see Muslims as human beings and this
exactly what he's doing cuz for him to
come and try to uh flip this whole story
on his head by talking about b b like
you said very clearly the mush Idol
worshipers were coming to kill the
Muslims and not only that inside Muslim
armies there were spies and maaf these
are hypocrites who were plotting to kill
the Muslims on top of that you've got an
enemy in front of you youve got Enemy
Inside you and you have a pact with B
which is a Jewish Community tribe which
betrayed that and anyone who is who goes
into war like War you will understand
that for example if America was to go to
war with Russia and UK is their allies
and UK backstabs them what do you think
they should be done with with United
Kingdom there would be severe
consequences on the fighting men that's
exactly what happened and you can see
brother and can see that it's not
civilians of women and children like
exactly and not only that we've had
we've seen rabbis we've seen Israeli
politicians we've seen IDF we've even
seen Israeli settlers these are your
common lay man who are clearly
perpetrating and admitting and saying
it's not Hamas we're targeting we want
to flatten Gaza so just imagine for a
moment and a second that we had Layman
Muslim saying we want to get rid of the
Jews as a as a whole and then you've got
the Muslim politicians saying yes this
is what we're going to do and then you
have the Muslim armies enacting that
there would be outright Global outrage
there would be chaos but this is the
point we do not have look rabbis are
coming out and saying they are quoting
amikit look you made a video on your
channel Benjamin Netanyahu even
mentioned this yes yes why are they
mention who's amikit amikit are a group
of people that went against uh God
Almighty and God almighty this is an
instruction of ethics of War told Moses
go to the amalik where's this 1 Samuel
15 yes 1 Samuel 15: 2 to3 and kill who
men men women children babies and even
donkeys now I want to ask question what
did the donkey do I asked that question
to a lot of Christians and the donkey do
I asked what did they do I don't think
anyone can answer it the point is what
they are the ones outright we ask
Douglas this this gutless coward show us
a single scripture in our Holy scripture
in any way on the Islamic tradition that
tells us to
it's a it's a of to kill men women
children and babies so how dare you
again it goes back to what the
dehumanization of Muslims he does not
want anyone not a single British person
to ever feel sorry for the musl for
what's happening zero that's why he
mentioned the story saying that they
because they didn't want to accept Islam
he fabricated them an absolute lie it's
an absolute lie now he looks like a fool
doesn't he but he's always looked like a
fool before this yeah he won't even find
anybody who's an Orient alist who agrees
with that characterization the story and
that shows you I mean this is a short
video but this individual here who's
been reluctant if not actually
completely um non-accepting of any kind
of debate he's a coward he's an absolute
joke of a human being and I think that
he's going to have to defend himself
either way but it's going to be in a
legal way when he's going to put in his
uh 32 in uh Blazer on his body and then
he's going to put his little shoes on
his size six shoes he's going to walk to
the courtroom and he's going to have to
defend himself for defamation of
character and the lawyers have already
put the summons to him and he's going to
hum be humiliated there as
well hey you are you wasting your time
on social media again your brothers and
sisters in Islam net from Norway are
establishing a Masid a DA Center
establishing a mid to convey The Message
of Islam is one of the best Deeds a
Muslim can do there's a huge need for it
in Norway you know this and I know this
so that makes the reward even greater so
give generously and Allah will give you
even
more